et selon morad el hattab écrivain
géopolitologue malgré le cessez-le-feu
les deux rivaux ne sont toujours pas sur
la même longueur d'onde en écoute
ils ne sont pas d'accord c'est pour ça
que les deux c'est celle ci ont été
présentés séparément
il ya une particularité donc communiqué
de ce sa rage qui est effectivement
soutenu par l'onu comme l'a rappelé
votre brillant reportages mais aussi
militairement par la turquie il appelle
à des élections présidentielle et
parlementaires le parlementaire sur une
base constitutionnelle mais il dit pas
laquelle on sait pas si le peuple libyen
va vraiment être consultées puisqu'il
n'est pas depuis 2011
mais là où il est très habile il demande
un cessez-le-feu l'arrêt des combats
afin de démilitariser des zones
contrôlées par le maréchal haftar c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi al majaz l'état n'a
pas fait communiquer et salary saclay
effectivement et le président du
parlement et qui est un soutien du
maréchal afta ne mentionne pas la
démilitarisation
donc vous voyez que les deux communiqués
présentés ne sont pas comment dire
concluant dans la mesure où en réalité
ces deux versions différentes